foreign
hey there fellow developers are you
tired of spending hours searching
through documentation discussion boards
and tutorials to find the right code
Snippets especially when building for
the cloud do you wish there was a fun
and efficient way to boost your coding
productivity well look no further
because I've got a perfect solution for
you with AI assisted development you can
say goodbye to syntax headaches and
hello to fast and efficient coding with
trustworthy good quality code
suggestions it understands your most
popular languages so you can get AI
driven code completion and suggestions
in multiple languages and most
importantly it's finally
original and building applique
applicator of all our Google Cloud
client libraries and coding samples it
is well versed in Google Cloud tasks
such as creating a cloud storage bucket
using python
and it isn't just for code completion
you can also chat with the rich
conversational experience to get
direction on your Cloud tasks all this
directly in your IDE or code editor get
gcloud command suggestions to create or
modify a cloud resource
[Music]
or learn more about deploying a service
since everything encoding starts with
hello world we are not going to break
that pattern now
let's take a spin and see how we can use
AI assisted development to deploy a
simple hello world application on cloud
run we can create a new main.py file
we're using Cloud workstations here
AI based code suggestions are available
across cloudworkstation Cloud shell
editor and vs code
that was fast AI just helped us generate
code
and just like that are serverless Hello
World Service is live and working with
AI assisted development you can focus on
the big picture and let the AI assistant
take care of the details plus it's just
plain fun to watch it work its magic
we are bringing this AI experience to
all the Google Cloud interfaces where
you code which means it is also in
bigquery editor enabling data Engineers
data scientists and data analysts to
develop queries faster
tuned on Google SQL it provides
assistance for contextual SQL code
completion enabling you to write better
SQL faster here I need a query to rank
the most frequently used features of my
app and I have it done using AI with AI
assistance you can also get contextual
SQL generation enabling you to bootstrap
complex queries in seconds
with this generative AI powered
interface for Google Cloud you can
tackle your next development project
with ease efficiency and fun intrigued
well sign up for our developer preview
program to get early access to our AI
powered Google Cloud experience
keep coding and having fun you all
[Music]